Today we are doing glow in the dark ping pong 2
But before that we have
something special for you guys
If you're looking for a
great Christmas present idea
We've got a campaign for you guys on our webshop
www.pongfinity.store
Every single order that includes a Pongfinity net
Will come with this epic Christmas
card signed by all three of us!
So for example if you order
three table tennis sets
You will get three Christmas cards
Now let's head to the glow studio!
Hey!
Emil turn the lights off!
Yeah!
Our previous glow video got almost 100k likes
So let's break it with this one
And don't forget about the
campaign on Pongfinity.store
It's only up for a limited time!
So head over there to do some Christmas shopping!
Until next time!